When you think space, you probably think
one space agency that travels
under the radar is ESA.
Which is surprising considering
what the European Space
Agency has achieved
and how vital it is to
the global space industry.
We've collaborated with
pretty much everybody
who is involved in space exploration.
But ESA wants to be a leading force
in furthering humanity's
mission into space.
For the first time,
we're playing a key role
in a human space flight mission
that goes beyond low Earth orbit.
Commander Ground, do you copy?
Copy.
No sampling.
If we want to have successful
human missions to Mars,
we are going to have to
learn to live and work
off-world in a different way.
The place where we are
going to learn to do that
is on the Moon.
In a world where working together
seems to be getting
more and more difficult,
can ESA help humanity
take its next giant leap?
Established in 1975, ESA
touches most corners of Europe.
Unlike other agencies,
it's a diverse collective.
The European Space Agency
is an inter-governmental organization
with 22 member states from Europe.
The core to ESA's success
is that international collaboration.
Its formative years were mainly spent
working in conjunction with NASA
and its record in space is pretty special.
From launching the world's
first high orbit telescope
and studying comets up close,
perhaps its most famous mission
was launched with NASA in 1990.
We joined with NASA to build
the Hubble Space Telescope
and of course that's been flying now
for more than 30 years.
Hubble has since discovered
more distant objects than
any terrestrial instrument.
In 2003, ESA launched
the Mars Express orbiter,
the first fully European
mission to a planet.
Since then, there's been the
farthest landing from Earth
made on Saturn's moon Titan,
and the first robotic landing on a comet.
ESA has also invested in
Earth observation satellites,
telecommunications and even
built Europe's own GPS system.
But its astronauts haven't journeyed
beyond the 400 kilometer orbit
of the International Space Station.
We've never played a key role
until now in human exploration
beyond low Earth orbit.
But with the Artemis
mission, which will enable us
to send humans back to the
Moon for the first time,
ESA is a central part of that.
ESA has built the service
module of the Orion Crew Vehicle
and the NASA and ESA astronauts
that will ride on that capsule to the Moon
will be powered by European technology.
In 2019, ESA ministers
committed to its biggest ever budget,
an approved and ambitious
portfolio of space programs.
While ESA cannot compete
with the likes of NASA
when it comes to spending,
ESA provides valuable science
services that have made it
an essential partner in
NASA's Artemis program.
ESA will contribute habitation
and refueling modules
along with enhanced communications.
It'll also be responsible
for operating elements
on the Lunar Gateway,
a permanent station in
orbit around the Moon.
The Lunar Gateway has
two functions really.
It's the first place that humans will go
to live and work for extended
periods beyond Earth's orbit.
So we're really exposing humans
to a location which is in deep space
where the environment and the conditions
are very different from what
we find on the space station.
This gives us a test
bed, somewhere to learn
how to live and work in deep space
for long periods of time.
It's also somewhere where we can perform
scientific research which will prepare us
for future exploration in deep space.
We're also working on
a large lunar lander,
which would take cargo,
logistics, robotics
and other equipment to
the surface of the Moon
as a contribution to the human missions
that are going to follow during the 2020s.
The first human missions
to return to the surface of the Moon
are planned for the latter
part of this decade.
Those could be followed by the buildup
of infrastructure and capability.
So we could be seeing a
sustained presence on the Moon
into the 2020s.
Sustainability is going to be based
on having the infrastructure
and the facilities
to enable long-term access
and if you want to do that on the Moon
in a long-term sustainable way,
we're going to have to
learn to use the resources
that we find locally wherever we can.
If you can take the regolith,
the ground up dusty rocky powder
that we find at the lunar surface,
if we can then bind that together,
we can create structures.
Those structures can protect us
from the very hot and
very cold environment,
so create some thermal shielding.
We can also use it to
create radiation shielding
and so it's regular 3D printing
where you take this stuff
and you 3D print it into
the structures you need.
It's a really exciting technology
for future applications.
Gravity on the Moon is much lower
than it is on Earth,
so launching a rocket
off the lunar surface
would potentially be easier
as it requires much less thrust.
Less thrust means less fuel,
making room in the rocket
for the essential payloads
to get humans to Mars and beyond.
The Moon's polar regions also have
large supplies of water ice,
which could be broken down
into oxygen and hydrogen,
useful ingredients needed
for humans to breathe
and rockets to fly.
This return to the Moon
will prepare us for Mars.
So we're going to be performing
cutting edge science,
the like of which has
never been done before.
Humans last stepped onto the Moon
nearly 50 years ago.
Now, multiple nations, including
China, Russia and India
all have planned missions.
Unlike the Apollo missions,
which lasted just days,
new missions will be much longer
because we now think the Moon
can teach us so much more.
Off the coast of West Africa,
Lanzarote's volcanic landscape
might be the closest thing
to the lunar surface here on Earth.
It's why ESA comes here
to run its Pangea program,
a specialized international
training course for astronauts.
Some of the reasons that we're
gonna go back to the Moon
are to look at very early
planetary system formation
so we can understand
the Earth Moon system.
Commander Ground, we wanted to...
As well as Europeans,
ESA is training NASA
astronaut Dr. Kate Rubins.
Rubins has already
spent 300 days in space,
but as part of NASA's Artemis program,
she's likely to become the
first woman to walk on the Moon.
It's very stark, it's very volcanic,
and that's actually similar to the Moon.
There are ancient volcanoes on the Moon.
Even the regolith on the
Moon is this kind of glassy
volcanic rock that we see here.
You're looking at hundreds
of millions of years of time
and our hope is to discover some of these
very, very early rocks.
Possibly, these rocks would be thrown up
through the magma near a volcano.
So today, we are taking
the physical samples of
the rock and the biology,
but we're also taking things like spectra.
So we can shoot some light at the rock
and see what bounces back at us
and different minerals
are gonna bounce back
different spectral patterns.
The Moon's a fantastic laboratory
for understanding the solar system.
Unlike on Earth, where
we have plate tectonics,
we have an atmosphere, we have water,
it kind of destroys the
rock record a little bit.
On the Moon, we don't have any of that.
So actually, it's very much like it was
in its early history
and in fact, people have talked about
finding parts of Earth on
the Moon that are much older
than a lot of the rocks
we can find on Earth
and they're still in a more pristine state
because the Moon hasn't had the overturn
that you get on the earth.
Commander Ground, do you copy?
The Pangea training course
isn't just preparing these
astronauts for the Moon.
It's training them to
look for signs of life
that might be more likely
elsewhere in the solar system.
Volcanic environments
look very barren on Earth.
There's rocks with no plants often,
especially if they're very fresh
volcanic environments, very new.
But in reality actually,
there's a lot of microbial life
living in rocks and on rocks
and in all sorts of parts
of a volcanic environment
like you can see around me.
So understanding the places
where the most interesting biology is
is very important for training astronauts
in terms of what they should
target when they go to Mars,
and also just for scientists to understand
where we should look for
searching for life on Mars.
This was a day where they
were letting us be autonomous.
So we were making some of the discoveries
like we would do on the lunar surface.
So some of the things that we were finding
were very interesting was an area
where there was some possible
maybe hydrothermal vents
or some water interaction coming up
and we could see some
alterations in the minerals.
So that kind of thing would
be incredibly important
and very valuable if we saw
that on the surface of Mars.
This would be an example of
a place that you would stop
and do a lot of sampling for life.
The other thing that's really important
is the context of the sample.
So we need to know this isn't just a rock
that we plucked off the
ground, but where is it?
Is it close to the hot spring?
Is it near the volcano?
Was it an early sample?
Was it a later sample?
All of that kind of
metadata is really critical
in understanding that geo
biology sample in the context
of everything else that was
going on in the environment.
The Moon could serve as a proving ground
for the technologies of the future,
helping humanity learn how
to live and work in space
and launch missions to bodies
further than ever before, like Mars.
If you look at the surface of Mars,
there's lots of channels that
have been carved by water.
Early on in its history,
it was probably a very different planet,
probably a lot more habitable,
much more conducive to life.
Potentially, there's a lot we can learn
about what biology is in terms of
kind of a feature of the universe.
We can learn by going to Mars
because perhaps it was habitable early,
but maybe life never developed,
so we need to understand why that is,
or if life developed how
long it lasted there,
maybe it was transferred to Earth,
maybe it was transferred
from Earth to Mars.
So there's all sorts
of different questions
that could get answered by
understanding more about Mars.
In ESA's Planetary Robotics Lab
in the Netherlands, scientists maneuver
a half scale version of the ExoMars rover,
part of a mission due to launch in 2022.
To date, only NASA and
China have landed rovers
on the red planet.
Joining them would be a coup for ESA.
Along with several other
high-tech instruments,
the ExoMars rover will be
the first that can drill
to a depth of two meters,
something that could deliver
groundbreaking science
for the agency.
We believe that material
brought from below the surface
has a better chance to bring
some interesting discoveries
because the samples would
have been basically protected
by the depths from the heavy radiation
and the turmoil cycles
that apply on the surface
and which may be explain
why so far the samples
taken over from the surface didn't reveal
anything very interesting.
The planet is not that far from the Sun
and therefore the temperature
experience on the planet
are still adequate for
the development of life.
The planet has also a
kind of similar region
and development as planet Earth
and therefore we can hope to
find traces of biological life
if we properly sound
the soil of the planet.
The rover was a difficult realization,
but I believe we are there.
We must wield the technology
to do this sort of vehicle,
not only the vehicle,
but also the integration
of science instruments
and the realization of the
laboratory and of the drill
which allows to pick up the samples
from underneath the surface.
ESA has suffered setbacks
with its Mars missions before,
so the stakes are high.
For this mission, ESA is
working with Roscosmos.
The Russian space agency is providing
the landing craft and the rocket
to deliver the European rover.
Russia's involvement came after NASA said
it could no longer fund the purchase
of two U.S. Atlas V rockets of ExoMars.
It serves as an example
of what the space industry can achieve
through bilateral exchanges,
most often seen on the
International Space Station.
That's not to say partnerships
are always easy to manage.
The evolution of the political world today
makes the setting of such
cooperation a bit more at risk.
If I take the example of ExoMars,
the corporation was started at a point
when the relationship
between Europe and Russia
were relatively satisfactory.
But this relation have
worked so enormously
since invasion by Russia
of Crimea and Ukraine
and now we have basically
to deal with a partner
which is much more attentive
to the way we deal with them,
much more secretive on the
information they reveal,
meaning that the risk
level of their deliverable
is increasing for us and waiting a lot
on the chance of success of the mission.
So we are basically to
take all those parameters
into account when setting
a corporation knowing that
going alone about those
big and complex mission
is something that so far we cannot afford
from a budgetary point of view.
So we are still in any case
to adopt cooperative good
to deliver big ambitious mission,
like the mission landing a rover on Mars.
One of my favorite phrases is
that space may be a vacuum,
but it doesn't take place in one,
meaning that politics are of course
an incredibly important part
of everything that we do.
Countries like China and India
are starting to challenge
the U.S's position
as leaders in space
technology and exploration,
competition which appears to be at odds
with ESA's core collaborative mission.
Our take on the old school space race
is kind of behind us.
The way to achieve the big
goals, which phases now,
whether that's looking down at the Earth
or looking out into the
universe, is best done together.
In space exploration, at the moment,
I think we see a coming together
of two things that are a little different.
One is international cooperation
and the other is competition.
I think different countries,
different agencies,
different public and private actors
are aiming to have their own capability
to access and operate
different places in space
and on the Moon.
As we build these different capabilities,
we create competition.
It also drives innovation,
it drives down costs
and it makes it space more
accessible to everybody.
So I think that this is
a very positive thing.
Bringing together the value added
of working as a community
in Europe has allowed us
to achieve much more than
any country in Europe
could have achieved on its own.
It's not just the sum of the parts,
it's much greater than that.